so with all the trials and tribulations
with drifter and your goal to me to make
a film before 30 film eventually ended
up on Netflix yeah I mean it was um yeah
it was pretty quick turnaround to it
just quite shocked I mean like it was
yeah the whole like first quarter of
like 2017 last year was pretty hectic
because it was like cuz I I was like and
I was prepping I was like in the
thickness of like prepping master party
and meeting with all these actors to
that and and then drifter was like
screening at UCLA and then it finally
went to had a little theatrical run at
this like art house theater in Hollywood
and then and then it went to iTunes and
like Amazon and all that afterwards and
then like and then once we were filming
monster party it went to Netflix on in
May of last year so no one had any more
excuses to not watch the movie so like
everyone started watch it then and that
like that helps so much they went to
Netflix and and you know it's like you
know when it goes in a flex you guys say
you start to like learn about the
darkness of the internet and the trolls
and and and the you know everyone has an
opinion and everyone loves to comment
and them a certain point they all just
start saying the same thing and you just
stop you know you start like you know
just I don't you know you don't worry
there's no point responding to any of
them I just don't respond anyone you
know like I mean if they're like
obnoxious comments you know it's like
you just didn't get the movie like but
um but yeah I mean like you definitely
like helped a lot I mean cuz like the
people then there were people that like
totally loved and totally got what the
movie was and and you know it's you know
got some very nice messages from people
and some not so nice messages from
people and so so you know it's like but
you know like that's that's know if
you're gonna yeah we're gonna make
movies I mean like just gotta be
thick-skinned you know it's like you
just gotta embrace it you know but like
but yeah it was yeah it was very
interesting a time when when alert alert
like because I just wasn't expecting the
movie to get as much exposure as it did
I thought it was gonna you know get like
a little like you know how small you
know a small distributed and just like
sort of like just move on but then like
when I'm like like The Hollywood
Reporter's writing about and like any
wires right now like oh and and then
it's like you know really getting
released all over the world I'm like
well there you are you know and and
every decision you made is
all up there for everyone to watch and
but it's like I don't you know it's like
I don't regret anything it's like I look
back it's like I mean that's that time
that was exactly the movie I wanted to
make you know like so it's like I mean I
just want to be just push the soundtrack
push all that stuff just maximize the
aesthetic and to see where you got to
pull back for later movies because it's
not sparkly it's like you know it's a
similar kind of like you know kind of
genre hybrid kind of storytelling but
like I mean it's still a very different
movie at the same time like all the
mistakes that I learned on that movie
that people had no problem telling me
about I I feel like I learned a lot from
that I think I always read like you know
handful of bad reviews and all that you
just want to like like know what bothers
people what doesn't work for people and
and you know like just fix that stuff
and and and you know like mouths parted
we spent like a year on the script you
know I mean I just wanted to make sure
that it was you know I mean just the an
improvement I just want to make sure if
anything else I just want to make sure
was an improvement I feel like it is
yeah it's interesting because I was
watching an interview with Margaret
Atwood it was a BBC documentary or
something and she was talking about her
first book did blew out the numbers that
they had projected yeah and someone gave
her the advice and you just looked at
her and he said now they can shoot at
you yeah and especially to where does
this darkness come from yeah I must have
gone through these traumatic things no
this is just what I write about you
don't have to have experienced them to
go to that level of darkness and so yeah
she talked about it as well so that
flipside of wow I mean did you really
think that drifter was going to get to
that level when you were making it or
you just needed to fulfill a goal for
yourself
I'd need a feel fulfilled goal and I had
I had no idea that was gonna get the
kind of exposure it got and I think it
was great in the long run I mean it did
everything I needed it to do so I've no
regrets about any of them but you know I
mean like I you know I mean like if
there was if there was one regret I just
wish we spent a little more time in the
screenplay and I wasn't so unbelievably
in patience you know because I'm a very
antsy kind of person and but but now
I've like grown so much I think as a
filmmaker after that because then we
like kind of changed a lot of things
though I want to
thing so it's like now it's like I'm
I've like grown to actually love writing
now and like want to spend a lot of time
on the screenplay and not just want to
you know cuz I think drifter I was just
like at that point I was really
concerned about just like visual
construction and like and composition
and aesthetic and in style
cuz that movies all that style there's
you know it's all but the mood and the
atmosphere and the music and style
there's nothing really much more to it
it's that's very much what it's about
it's like a big music video or something
and and that's just like that's at that
time that was the kind of movie I want
to make and now I'm much more interested
in like proper character development
proper narrative because I that's why I
mean drifter was a very particular kind
of movie because like you my shorts or
nothing like that movie at all it was
like that movie I was like let me just
get this like ultimate nostalgic movie
out of my system and and just purge
myself and you know just chock-full of
all the stuff that I've always wanted to
do you know just the things that um I've
loved growing up and all these like all
these obscurities and just like push
everything to the max for beginning to
end and and just see where it lands you
know and it was very like I was very
polarizing movie when it came out I
thought was a very interesting reaction
and Lily gothics I was like really does
such a small tiny little movie and you
know it generated like a very like
polarizing emotion from people like a
lot of people take it very personally
with that movie like there was the way
they were like reacting to it so I was
like I mean it's like I say as long as
they react it's like I don't care if
they love it or hate it I just want
people to react to it and I have an
opinion about it you know whether it's
good or not cuz like you know if you
really good or if you believe the good
reviews you have to believe the bad
reviews so it's like at a certain point
it all just becomes like moot and just
like you just don't you know like
they're all helpful but it's like they
don't they you shouldn't let what he was
like because they the good reviews don't
matter and the batter views don't matter
and like in the grand scheme of things
but like I think it's just good to you
know just read them a little bit not
being so distant from them because I
think they're taking the time to write
about your movie they might be crapping
all over it but they are taking the time
to write about them and I mean at the
time when Holly reporter like I was like
I was like wow this is like a tough
tough business when I you know they they
gave a review there was a you know not
not
the best and and and and it's like you
know they're not wrong like that's how
they feel and but I I just like reading
that stuff and like even even when
they're criticizing it they're still
complimenting it inside of those crews
you know it's like you know I think a
lot of people thought it was like a much
bigger movie so I mean like you know I
don't think like it being a small movie
should ever dictate how harsh you're
gonna be on something it's still just
the movie itself but it's like I do
think some people literally did think
that it was like a million and like and
and it you know just wasn't at all it
was like you know like peanuts names Lee
I just and so I mean I thought I was
kind of funny that like they were kind
of giving like almost like backhanded
compliments in a way but but you know
yeah yeah you know I think embrace the
embrace the bad reviews embrace all that
stuff because it's just all part of
making movies you know how did you get a
distribution deal for it myself
mythographers had a came across a sales
agent at the South by Southwest early
2015 and he'd asked him if he had any
movies that he was working on like
horror films and this was one that he
we're in soft prep for and no I know
with him right before he about the shoot
and then he switched over to a different
company like a sales agency company and
then he just kept on kept in touch with
the movie I was like sending MALDI
Stills and he came to set a couple times
and then and then then we cut a trailer
for the American film market in 2015
which was very very much like just its
commercial other trailers we can make it
just very much like straight forward
action thriller cannibal movie and like
our movie is like not that at all I mean
it has all that stuff in it but it's not
it's a weird note and so you know make a
trailer till a show at afn and I get
buyers to be interested in it and and
there was like a couple distributors
that he was constantly talking to for a
while while we were editing the film and
I hated showing work-in-progress
versions of the movie I'm like no one's
gonna truly be able to experience this
movie until it's mixed like this like
it's just a very specific kind of like
hybrid tonal poem kind of like
whacked-out kind of experience and like
the soundtrack is so paramount for this
movie and like 10 cent like I just need
to finish the movie before you truly see
what this thing
and I think that almost about everything
it's like I just I'd never think the
movie is good until it's finished I just
don't I mean
and when I say finished I mean like
mixed like that I think the mixing is
like the temple for the movie and people
underestimate that a lot just like
adjusting violence but I think it's like
really much more than that and all the
little nuances really dictate the
experience and yeah and he was like so
he was I really loyal in the film and
then yeah I mean we were the couple
minutes after we finished the movie in
like April 2016 we had like a little
friends-and-family screening and then a
couple months later we were able to lock
in like a u.s. distributor and then
learning all about like deliverables and
all like that we were getting like the
document it was like it gives you a
migraine like your brain starts bleeding
just like reading all these things just
like oh my god a nightmare but with any
show it's like you know your sound mixer
and your editor and your assistant
editor and then it's much more you know
they understand it much more clear
it's just so so overly technical the way
it's described and it's so many things I
got to send but but yeah I mean like
then you know then yeah like we're up to
and you know they ended up releasing the
movie in like February of 2017 but
Australia released the film first like
round Halloween of 2016 so I was like on
DVD out there and then and then after
that like then the following spring it
started like snowball and go US and
Canada and Germany and all these
different places and almost seeing all
these like fake posters that like
Germany made and always that and seen
things like hey posters like you know
some are awesome actually but like some
I see them it's like well it's it's good
artwork but it's like it's so
unbelievable like sign we're like one
poster said like like like the Book of
Eli meets whatever it's like this movie
is like it's like a it's like a weird
like acid trip David Lynch II and it's
like not it's you know it has like cool
action stuff in it but it's like not you
know it's not like this movie that
you're just describing to people you
know so I thought that was kind of like
kind of funny but exhaled like some
people when they see the movie you're
like but III just think that I think
that's kind of fun though when people
like sometimes like our markets
thing and then they see something like
when Drive came out I never thought it
was like that furious and there some
people were singing but I think that's a
nice surprise that sometimes you know
you